what's up everyone we have the xiaomi 13
Pro in the office today for our gaming
test this is turning out to be quite
insane on the photography front check
out what Bobby has to say in this review
here we are going to be running this
phone through our gaming Gauntlet Genji
impact pubg mobile Call of Duty mobile
and Diablo Immortal this phone is
boasting some competitive specs too
performance wise the xiaomi 13 Pro is
packing a Snapdragon 8 Gen 2 12 gigs of
RAM 512 gigs of storage and an adreno
740 all of this plays out on a 6.73 inch
OLED 120hz high-res display and a 4820
milliamp hour battery with Hyper turbo
and reverse charging now before we run
the test let's do a baseline of the
temperatures on the front and the back
at the top of the phone here it says
that currently it's a 33.5 degrees
Celsius internally we are going to be
checking out the front
it's 32 on the surface right now the 2.7
33 34 down here somewhere
okay you know still 32 all right in the
back
33 31
and oh this is actually oh this is a
beautiful bag
and
yeah 32-ish 31-ish
also we are currently at 84 battery
let's just run our first test which is
getting to the impact and we're going to
be running all the games on the game
Turbo hub
okay
so first game we're going to be playing
is Genji and impact
right also there is a game boost
available down here with a game turbo
mode and let's just try boosting
everything up
we're going to be using everything we
can to tackle all of the graphic
intensive games that we have on hand
and let's just get in
all right now that we're in game let's
just check our settings real quick all
right so graphics and everything is set
on the highest with 60 FPS right now and
yeah everything is turned on so let's
just get into the game right so dialogue
is looking really good his model it's
very Sheen lighting 80s piano is coming
off very well off his buttons over here
and I mean there's pretty much no
sunlight but there is Moonlight and it's
reflecting off really nicely off the
details on his shirt so let's just go to
Inazuma and see how this performs like
in a dense city with a ton of NPCs all
right we're still waiting in the Zuma
right now but the thing is we are not at
the top so let's just run up so far it's
running pretty smoothly and as you can
see down here game boost rise it's kinda
jumping up a little bit here and there
animals are dropping like maybe like one
or two frames so that's nice that we
have an inbuilt FPS content on here
so
let's just get to the top real quick so
far we're experiencing Fury it drops at
about 2 FPS so it's kind of toggling
between 61 FPS and 59 FPS so that's a
little bit but honestly it isn't too
jarring so that's okay in my books not
sure about you guys but I'm pretty much
fine with that
so we are here at the top of all my load
look at the scenery it's amazing and it
looks really good rendering is pretty
far off actually and just nice we are
entering
a new dawn a new morning and look at
that his animations are pretty smooth
Shadows all working off very nicely and
I'm hoping to get some sunlight here in
a bit but just look at the effects of
the sakuras falling off the trees looks
really good and Here Comes the Sun
and let's just get a closer look at that
look and let's see how the Sun bounces
off his face
that looks beautiful
all right so let's move on downstairs
all right so far when it comes to
running up and down it's not nothing
much
we are walking through right now nothing
much going on it's still pretty smooth
from what I'm seeing
but it is heating up on my left hand on
here where the main camera is at and I
will say that this one is huge it's nice
it's a nice snugly fit into my hands but
the camera does get in the way of things
so just take note of that but I'm liking
the look of genshin on the xiaomi 13 Pro
so let's just go into the Wilderness and
maybe get to a fight
okay it is getting kind of hot down here
all right let's just do a quick mid
check
38.5 at the back yeah it is heating up a
little bit
ran up like what five degrees all right
let's check the front real quick
right 40 degrees the one it feels kind
of toasty all right let's check the size
because that's why I'm feeling the heat
the most actually
36 37 but mostly around like 40ish on
this side but on the right side
39 not too far off so yeah it is kind of
hard right now but it's not super
uncomfortable
so yeah look at that running distance
pretty damn far off
it's beautiful look at the fog on that
side and whoo what is that over there I
have no idea but
okay we got some healing shows up there
[Music]
there you go this Shaman as well
oh let's try it all through it
all too quick nice
all right it looks good honestly it
comes the Altis but I'm seeing wait we
still have more tangles in the area
what are you at oh there you go
[Music]
nice okay let's clean that chest and you
know this viral bit sofa combat is
pretty smooth I haven't seen like a huge
dip in fps when it comes to unleashing
the ultimates but we'll see how it feels
like in a more dense combat experience
when we hit on 3D spiral Abyss let's
start this challenge real quick
a lot of stuff going on
all three real quick
destroyed
in seconds
drop these up
[Applause]
let's try it all these
very smooth
all right that again
let's try one more
nice suit you got it you got it
thank you
all right let's go for us
[Applause]
nice
okay
can get this guy I just Fusion
all right
nicely done let's go for one more
actually
great I'm actually enjoying myself quite
a bit
I haven't seen any like drastic training
joke whatsoever but
[Applause]
yes let's just put in all the on
everyone yeah it is okay this is part of
a test it's okay it's fine
let's go get to the tape
very nice
let's just see him with this
and then one more let's press one on
[Applause]
[Music]
very nice so I haven't experienced any
drastic premium jobs animals maybe won't
buy one or two frames but other than
that it's pretty much fine let's do a
final temperature check before we head
on to the next game and
it is now at 40 degrees
39 degrees all right at the back
26 39-ish
37ish at the back as well but it's
mostly hot on the front and on the sides
too wow that's actually pretty hot let
me check that
we're hitting around 36 or some reason
but you know what the phone is hot right
the phone is hot so let's just move on
to the next game we are currently at 77
percent
okay so let's play pubg mobile all right
we are out of the heels of Genji and Pat
we're gonna be playing pubg mobile right
now let's check the temperatures on the
front
hopefully this cool down a little bit
yeah it has from the 41 degrees it was
just on the left side and I'll check the
right side
okay safe to say that the phone is
cooled down a little bit on the front
let's check the back
35 ish 36 ish okay so it's safe to say
the phone has cooled down quite a bit we
are currently at 75 Battery and
temperature wise internally we had 40.3
degrees internally so let's play some
pubg mobile okay so again the Boost
thing is basically just to clear the
other processes if you go performance
mode obviously it will heat your phone
up a lot faster but we're trying to see
how it's like without performance mode
you know in the case that you're playing
games more on the go whatever and you
don't want to drain your phone's battery
all right so now that we're in game
let's check the settings real quick okay
so graphically we are at Ultra HD we're
Ultra frame rate classic style ntel sync
let's just go to false okay you can't do
fall still two times uh let's just go
Shadows enabled everything else is
enabled so let's press OK and let's just
get into a game
all right a little bit of ferment drops
here and there but nothing too drastic
in the lobby let's see animations
all right let's just mute everyone
C130 is looking pretty good look at the
sun bouncing off it's exterior and let's
see how things look when we jump in and
everyone's following me because I'm a
job master so let's see where we're
gonna land
let's go pachinki okay one two three
so far it is looking pretty all right I
can't really tell we're still a bit too
far off and there's too many clouds but
jumping in is smooth so far
okay it is rendering everything's
running in right now
looking pretty smooth let's just get in
there
hopefully we don't die and we land
all right I'm gonna get those in for you
that house on the right side that far
right house
and I've got a lot of people on me I
think
I hope not
oh wait nevermind yeah oh okay that's a
teammate okay it's fine
all right just nice we got a landing on
the house let's just get some real
quick
okay it's a bit too dark for you guys
let me just
change it up a little bit
all right okay
okay let's see what we got okay so
navigating the UI is pretty smooth okay
okay so now we're getting the UI is all
right actually honestly this screen size
is perfect for the game because you can
kind of reach everywhere so no matter
how you configure your settings you
should be able to play the game just
fine
all right you want to go to Pistol right
now let me change things up for real
coin tokens okay fine
you need to get a rifle of Swords oh he
needs shotgun
all right surprisingly not many people
have jumped in here yet
huh that's weird
[Applause]
all right where is it from it's on the
right side
here right side
[Applause]
oh okay we'll see we'll see
is this medium quick
all right a lot of fighting going right
now I can't see anyone
okay camera overheated for a little bit
uh
big guns right now but also where
everyone is
okay let's just buy some guns I think we
have enough tokens to cover something at
least okay but so far combat and
everything you can even call the combat
it's pretty smooth the game itself is
running very smooth and oh boy oh boy
yeah you see that
[Applause]
I can believe oh okay okay I see you now
pushing up here
[Applause]
there we go I believe that's a squat
down but that's just gonna start real
quick and get the hell out of here
a lot of Fire coming in from the church
I believe
[Applause]
where are you coming from
but as of now we have 40.1 degrees
Celsius and we are at 69 battery nice oh
where's that oh
[Applause]
there we go
okay
[Applause]
that's not fun that's really not fun
oh my god oh boy there's a lot of things
going on right now oh I'm gonna shop on
the side and everywhere great
come on
[Applause]
Jesus Christ hopefully you can't last
this round but currently we have 40.4
degrees Celsius at 68 and I don't think
that the front of the phone is like too
hard or anything so she's pretty it's
all right to touch right now you know
it's not super hot or anything it is a
bit warm but it's not super hot so it's
fine
let's just camp out in that house over
there then over there yeah we're gonna
talk to you guys and I really can't find
one
[Applause]
this is where did it and like oh okay
see
all right
I mean the final moments of the game
right now I'm just trying to find that
last player so we can secure the win and
I really can't find the dude at all
I mean okay Kevin we are on top of a
hill there's quite a bit of ground below
us
let's just ride around see what we get
okay so uh I did not get the guy in the
end so I just need to check the focus
real quick but yeah I did get the guy in
the end but our teammates obviously did
and we won the match so with that we are
currently at
56 after a full game which is about what
20 minutes ish and internally it's about
40.63 Celsius and there hasn't been any
like major feeling drops or anything I'm
not even like small ones maybe I'll buy
like one thing or two frames but other
than that it's fine it's buttery smooth
and it's not overheating at all but
let's check the temperatures on the
front real quick
39 38 and on the left right side 37.8
ish or okay that's actually that's
actually all right competition it's
still warm though that's what I'll say
on the back 35 ish
36 ish on the bottom half and on the
camera lenses 36.937 all right so uh
pubg is fun and it's buttery smooth on
the xiaomi 15 Pro so with that let's
move on to Call of Duty mobile this
video is brought to you by Asus check
out the Asus Zenbook 14x OLED Space
Edition commemorating the 25th
anniversary of the first Asus laptop
sent into space Not only does it offer a
space exclusive design but it's even
worthy of going where no man has gone
before with its space gray durability it
even comes with a 3.5 inch OLED
companion Zen Vision display and you
will have a ball of a time taking
interviews with a 16 by 10 4K OLED Nano
Edge Pantone validated 14 inch display
all right we pubg all the way we are
currently at 33.1 degrees Celsius
internally and we're running on 64
battery the front of the phone is at 32
we have allowed the phone to cool down
just a little bit also because our
camera has been overheating so fun times
but the front of the phone is cooled
down dramatically and the back as well
so with that said Okay God look at that
the back so I want 31 degrees 32 degrees
ish so it has cooled down quite a bit
so with that said let's just move on to
Call of Duty okay look at that the Mage
is looking really good oh look at that
it's kind the
drasticish FPS drop just now as you see
but you know what the game is loading up
so whatever
but with me just looking really good you
can see like the sun is bouncing off of
the jacket and his body suit really well
UH 60 looks damn good okay so with the
graphics here we are on very high
graphic quality here in frame rate and
Max I don't want to use ultra frame rate
because you just push it down to like
what medium or low and the thing is I
want to see how far I can push this
phone at the highest graphical settings
so
we're going out the multiplayer they
have a feel everything is turned on all
right so with the graphics set let's do
a quick game boost on the side and let's
see how much we can free up and I think
that should be it so let's just get into
a game
I'm travel without never seen that
before
all right let's look at there's the
details on our Hall so it's looking
pretty good let's enter the Sun and you
guys can see Shadows are hitting off
pretty well so let's just get into the
fight
through the syntax out
all right this one down
okay now mine
okay doing pretty all right
let's just push out because so far our
team okay we're winning by three it's
still a very slim margin but you know
we're gonna push it all the way up
here one down
one more down
of course because it's from and of
course because it's front line right we
need to push it up a little bit okay
that's always
pressure
this set it's a guy over there
damn it
got us good with the stunner
let's just use
an SMG
as you can see all the effects are
looking pretty sick on
this SMG version here oh okay never mind
got distracted but whatever let's just
push out again
okay we're still waiting by like five
we are running at 37.2 degrees Celsius
internally down here and I haven't seen
any like super huge clearly drops
whatsoever so you should be doing pretty
alright
enemy someone is all pretty good oh
the guns look really good at this game
and let's just push out
more into the website and try to get a
flank and an eye on the enemy to come on
that side but I think it's our team is
pretty much just camping them right now
let's get ready oh there's a lot of
weight over there
noise
and you reload
this push up again
they're all just on this side right now
[Applause]
let's throw this out
we're doing a little better in the
second half
hold on
[Applause]
nice
oh my
but so far again no drastically dropped
whatsoever this game is running very
smoothly and we've got to jump this one
that's great
oh nice nice nice nice nice
and we are done one more kill there we
go last kill the game with the swan hunt
and yeah we're 30.4 degrees Celsius
right now it is 61 battery rise and
there hasn't been any major fairy draws
whatsoever
animation has been screwed with the
models look great and after a single
match it looks pretty alright let's just
check the front real quick I do 637-ish
yeah it has been gone up a little bit I
think like five degrees correct me if
I'm wrong let's check the back
[Music]
okay 34-ish
35-ish so it doesn't it does heat up
just a little bit but it's not
uncomfortable to play and with that
let's just move on to the next game
let's go to Diablo Immortal we are
currently at 30.7 degrees Celsius we
took a little break and currently we are
at 59 battery and let's just check
temperatures real quick on the front
35.6 30 you know okay it's very cool
actually don't even check it that much
30 on the back as well
yeah it's cool to touch all right so
let's get into Diablo Moto all right
here we go cow food looking spam
fabulous as usual
blood on her dagger and look at that
Shield she's looking really good so
let's just get into the game and we'll
go into a dungeon all right so in West
March we're going to be checking our
settings real quick before we head into
the dungeon right now it's a little bit
dark if I'm not wrong so I'm just kind
of bump it up for you guys here we go
did she do fine
game boost let's just boost it up a
little bit
there we go all right we are good to go
and then through Graphics 60 FPS Ultra
still not available for any phones
image happening yeah why not
let's put everything on very high and
let's get into the game so right now
we're at 36.8 degrees Celsius internally
according to this thing here and let's
see we are currently 120 FPS
so let's just hide this real quick and
let's just get into a dungeon
let's go into the rift area
means
to keep attacking them
push up
the score going
and even with a lot of mobs on the
screen all these effects going on it's
still hanging itself pretty well this
xiaomi effect
[Applause]
this arches on the side
okay so again when it comes to the
screening and navigating the UI it's
still pretty alright like again I'll
show you that the screen size is perfect
because you can't reach everywhere even
with one hand which
but other than that you know it's just
that the lenses do get in the range so
again if you guys want to be playing
this and use up your game Driver for
gaming you may want to invest in a cover
just to alleviate that
all right here we go
just keep wrecking him
[Applause]
to go down right about
no there we go
all right so from here let's go direct
Plaza but before that let's do a quick
temperature check we are currently
running at 40.9 degrees Celsius down
here and North very jobs about from that
huge fight just now it's a and it's a
constant fight by the way it is getting
a bit warm so let's check the
temperatures out real quick
39 yeah it's heating a lot more compared
to Pub G and Call of Duty but then again
this is a quite graphically intensive
and we are using quite a number of the
additional settings in the graphics so
at the back it's 37
oh my gosh okay it's actually not too
bad at the back but the front is quite
warm so with that let's just head to the
cemetery and see how it's like and how
the phone fast when it comes to
open world
exploration
you can get through the big deal
actually all right now Mike
got a knight here it's just sticking
down quite beefy
but not as beefy I get a conduit shine
right now but the graphics and like the
weather and even like the effects on her
armor looks really sick and I think we
just found out left
yes this looks really good but as you
can see even with a ton of marks and
like you know the cultures and
everything going around right everything
is still working out pretty much fine
[Applause]
what would be great is that ability
where I can use the corpses as like
lenses like in Dead Space
because you can't do that as an
instrumental
[Applause]
but never mind he's done
he's gentle
[Applause]
it's all kill these spirits
put everything here
official artist upcoming Scout
it's not just be careful do not actually
close to it but yeah okay we have the
layer Garden got him
[Applause]
it's straight BTS there we go
okay all right so with the other
Immortal you know this game runs smooth
on you xiaomi take me so of course it is
heating up right now so we will check
the temperatures once I'm done killing
things around here and I guess we are in
the clear for now
lucky not really it's just gives you a
bit more fighting
all right so now that we're in a much
safer area I believe let's just check
out what we have around here currently
we have 41.9 degrees Celsius internally
according to this monitor down here and
we are at 48 battery it is getting a bit
toasty on the front so let's just check
the temperatures real quick
oh look at that 40 degrees on the left
side
and then 39 on the right side it is
evening out a little bit it is very
toasty actually but let's check the back
37 36 on the bottom half and on the top
where the lenses are 39 degrees 40
degrees so yeah this phone does get hot
but in terms of gameplay when it comes
to Diablo Immortal dealing with a lot of
mobs and effects this one can handle it
no questions asked
so with that let's just move on to our
conclusion
after this battle real quick
give me a second the xiaomi 30 Pro can
handle itself pretty well when it comes
to Performance especially engaging
impact and Diablo Immortal you can see
the Snapdragon 8 Gen 2 and the adreno
740 putting in the work on the beautiful
screen with all the effects and details
in game another thing to note is that
the battery levels for what it said
after four games with varying levels but
still intensive graphical settings yeah
this xiaomi 13 Pro is doing really good
its screen size is perfect for me at
least and the speakers are tailored for
Great Sound though it could do better in
terms of heat management with the
highest temperature reaching the 40
degree region and again you may need to
get a phone case to level out the phone
group or get used to it being there but
all in all it's a great one for gaming
and I can't wait to see what else xiaomi
has installed for us so if you have any
questions about the xiaomi 13 Pro leave
them in the comment section down below
and I'll do my best to get to them keep
up to date with us by following us on
all of our socials for the latest news
and if you like this video consider
hitting the like button and subscribe to
us it goes a long way also if you want
to watch more stuff from us check this
out
[Music]